Ordinary
ee
me
[applause]
feel love me
Wow, food at the academy
Today, the wind blows again among our friends It's disgusting as witches at the academy We're halfway through completing our missions together With Sho-kun
's cooperation, the sun will always torment us and even curses us  It can be eradicated
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, that's what Majesty wants on Queen
]
If you become a member of Kita New Dohi 8 Te Miso,
you can use all nuclear facilities.  Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh, so I'll
lend you a lot of benefits, so I'll lend you
F
-style GOONIE
Uhuuu U, it's not a cold current.
Edible three types of pen
Come on, it's pink chime
Why aren't we guys like this
just
now?  Days I
'll have to pay you back 1 ee